oh I just got an email that our app is
down apparently the database is hanging
we're losing transactions if we set up a
circuit breaker the app can respond to
the error rather than hanging but then
each of our services has to implement
its own logic for circuit breaking this
is an infrastructure problem why don't
we solve it with kubernetes and Sto let
me show you
so here's my website as you can see it's
a one-stop shop for everything you need
to buy in order to be the best hipster
that you can be it's built on google
kubernetes engine with the optional sto
add-on enabled one of the neat things
sto gives is visibility into everything
that's going on in this case I'm going
to use the open source Keala console to
show that as you can see I have two
micro-services my front end which is
talking to cloud memory store for
session caching and my product catalog
which is talking to cloud sequel for
product information pricing and that
kind of thing each tier has a concept of
versions and I have two versions of my
product catalog the working version and
the broken version the broken version
simulates the kind of issues I've seen
in the past where a service takes too
long to respond this could be due to a
stressed-out database with millions of
transactions waiting to be processed
perhaps these infrastructure issues or
networking problems whatever it is it's
things that make my entire website fail
I can tell you if I went to a website
that took 15 plus seconds to render a
webpage every time I clicked a link I'd
probably go to one of their competitors
and that's exactly what my broken
service simulates it takes a connection
holds it for 15 seconds and eventually
replies so even if a service is down we
can have our application handle the
error rather than just hanging right
with this geo you could enforce a
blackout rather than a brownout when the
service is misbehaving in the past you'd
have had to include all sorts of
libraries to do that it can get really
complicated let me show you how to do it
so let's turn on that broken version
send some traffic to it and show how SEO
can help one of the core concepts in
this Joe is a virtual service a virtual
service defines where my traffic is
routed within the mesh so I'm going to
say send 100% of my traffic to the
broken version of my micro service if I
apply that change and go back to my app
and refresh it you'll see Chrome is
hanging because my back-end service is
hanging at this point you've lost me as
a customer but worse if this was a
payment service you may have even lost a
sales record I've seen all this and
worse in the past due to these kind of
bugs so what can we do to mitigate it in
the past we might have used circuit
breaker libraries the problem with this
approach is that they're very language
specific so one app is written
Java and another and go they'll have
different libraries and sharing state
between them is difficult
SEO gives me a way to solve this with
circuit breaker patterns there are two
cool things at play here but first is my
destination rule the destination rule
defines not only the versions of my
application but also characteristics on
how they receive traffic in this case
I'm saying allow a maximum of 200
pending requests but I could also put
things like TCP session information and
all kinds of settings where I'm s to
understand what this app can deal with
and what its tolerances are in this case
I can never have more than 200 pending
requests the two hundred and first
requests will simply see Maya piss down
a blackout not a brownout the second
thing I can do is modify my virtual
service to change the maximum amount of
time a request can wait for my up to
reply by default this could be virtually
infinite but for some apps that's not
appropriate in the case of my catalog
service I never want to wait for more
than one second if I apply this change
now sto with that maximum of one second
will intercept the call which is taking
15 seconds and say no and instead give
me a 503 gateway error to my app which I
can deal with very easily and I can just
show that my catalog is offline the cool
thing about this is I've not changed a
single line of code and the very neat
thing is in my console I have visibility
of these broken requests I can see my
services down without waiting for my
users to go to a competitor great so now
our application is able to properly
handle the errors right and you only
need to change a little bit of config
didn't have to touch any of your code
don't forget to subscribe for more great
Google cloud platform content
[Music]